for those of you who are curious we will
go through an argument that establishes
that the set of real numbers is an
uncountable set it's a famous argument
known as Cantor's diagonal ization
argument actually instead of looking at
the set of all real numbers we will
first look at the set of all numbers X
that belong to the open unit interval so
numbers between 0 & 1 & such that their
decimal expansion involves only threes
and fours now the choice of 3 & 4 is
somewhat arbitrary doesn't matter what
really matters is that we do not have
long strings of nines so suppose that
this set was countable if the set was
countable then that set could be written
as equal to a set of this form X 1 X 2 X
3 and so on where each one of these is a
real number
inside that set now suppose that this is
the case let us take those numbers and
write them down in decimal notation for
example one number could be this one and
it continues forever since we are
talking about real numbers their decimal
expansion will go on forever
suppose that the second number is of
this kind and it has its own decimal
expansion suppose that the third number
is again with some decimal expansion and
so on so we have assumed that our set is
countable and therefore the set is equal
to that sequence so this sequence
exhausts all the numbers in that set can
it do that
let's construct a new number in the
following fashion the new number looks
at this digit and does something
different looks at this digit the second
digit of the second number and does
something different looks at the third
digit of the third number and does
something different and we continue this
way this number that we have constructed
here is different from the first number
they differ in the first digit is
different from the second number it's
different in the second digit it's
different from the third number it's
because it's different in the third
digit and so on so this is a number and
this number is different from X I for
all I so we have an element of this set
which does not belong to this sequence
therefore it cannot be true that this
set is equal to the set formed by that
sequence and so this is a contradiction
to the initial assumption that this set
could be written in this form and this
contradiction establishes that since
this is not possible that the set that
we have here is an uncountable set now
this set is a subset of the set of real
numbers since this one is uncountable it
is not hard to show that the set of real
numbers which is a bigger set will also
be uncountable and so this is this
particular famous argument we will not
need it or make any arguments of this
type in this class but it's so beautiful
that it's worth for everyone to see it
once in their lifetime